have you wondered how hormones control
us so hormones are produced by glands in
the endocrine system of our body right
such as a pituitary gland or the adrenal
gland okay now these hormones are
released into the bloodstream and travel
to different parts of the body and they
bind themselves to specific receptors
and these receptors will send signals to
cells to change their behavior yes
that's how it happens hormones control
so many important functions in our body
such as growth and development
metabolism reproductive functions and
even controls aspects like our mood our
sleep cycle Etc in fact have you heard
of Marathon this hormone actually
regulates on Steam Cycles tell me in the
comment section below which hormone
makes us happier okay and for more such
videos subscribe to normalness